although it may not seem like he's doing
much this professional gamers heart is
under stress as he performs more than
300 movements per minute then some
Rollins maybe I can feel like my heart
is beating fast all I guess like where I
take a deep deep breath the ESL
championship in duisburg brings together
some of Jimmy's top gamers researchers
from the German sports university in
Cologne have provided heart rate
monitors to see what effect eSports has
on the body compared to traditional
sports we're trying to figure out how
does the gaming have an influence on our
heart race on a hard race on our stress
load while gaming in sports you have
physical stress and in eSports it's like
more mental stress a big crowd can add
to the pressure while gamers are
desperate not to let teammates down for
me it's positive like when I hear the
crowd cheering or when we are on stage
because you are really a team and
everyone is having the same goal even
though crystal and his team weren't able
to take the title they at least got more
of a workout than they might have
expected